サッバパパッサアカラナン クサラッソウパサンパダ
サチットパリヨダパナン エータンブッダナサーサナン
皆様方 よろしくお願いします
在京のご僧様方 お手元の教会の皆様方と中堅の大使館と皆様方
今日は我々はお釈迦様の悟りをお祝い
祝う国際的なウェーサー祭典をここで行います
日本では日にちの問題がありますから
いろんなところで私たちはね
ウェーサーカマッシルをやってやって
名古屋と大阪とか どちらで時々別なところでもね
四国の方でもウェーサーカマッシルをやって
もしかすると今日で終了かもしれません
で 人類の中で 生命の中で
この地球上の歴史の中で現れた唯一聖なる素晴らしい存在はお釈迦様です
お釈迦様の教えが 時代がどう変わっても
人間の生き方がどう変わっても変わらない
面白いです 一切の現象は無常であると真理を語っている仏教では
ブッダにとっての真理は変わらないということです
真理は変わらない 地球が丸いということも変わるかもしれません
それは皆様方はよく知っていると思います
仏教を学んでいるんだから
伝統的にお釈迦様の誕生
成仏 涅槃という 3つをまとめてウェーサーカマッシルを行いますが
よくよく研究してみると
ウェーサーカマッシルはお釈迦様の悟りを入れたこと
これこそ生命の革命的な出来事なんです
梵天 神々 人間 みんなに革命を起こす出来事は
お釈迦様が悟りを入れたことなんです
仏典によると ものすごい他の
宇宙のね もう何万個も他の宇宙の生命たちもこの刺激を受けました
だから当時では神話やと思ったでしょうね
仏教は昔からもね 地球のこれだけ生命ではないとは言わないんですね
あまりの無数の星たちがありましてね
そちらもいろいろ生命体がいるんだと
その中で地球に関係あるセクションが梵天
神々と人間 地獄 餓鬼道
畜生道とどうかなってますけどね
それでお釈迦様が真理を発見したんですね
何を発見したんですかというと
この世の中で何一つも一定した現象はありません
一切流動的で動で ダイナミックで止まらない
流れ 流れの流れ だから私というものはありえない
それは流れです 流れなんだから
意図的にこれストップしないとストップもできません
この流れの法則が因果法則ということです
これは私の流れは何なのかと
私の悩み 苦しみの流れは何なのか
私の不満の流れは何なのか
なんで生きているのかという問題を観察したところで真理を発見して
最後に 最初に喜びの言葉を語られたんです
はい 読み上げます  ヤタハレパトゥバワンティダンマ アタピノジャヤトブラフマナッサ アタッサカンカーワ
パヤンティ サッバダヤヤトパジャナーティ サヘトゥダンマン
意味を訳します 物事の現象のありのままの姿があらわになってくるんだと
見えてくるんだと アタピノジャヤトブラフマナッサ
修行者が励んで観察すると
頑張って観察すると 一切の現象はどのようにあらわになっていくのか
どのようにどのようなことで見えてきます
その時は一切心にある疑いが消えて消えるんだよ
何の疑いがない 何の疑問もない
心は晴れて安穏に達するんだ
というのは ヤトパジャーナティサヘドダンマ
すべての現象はこれからこれが現れる
これだからこれが現れると知っているんです
これ知っていると一切の疑いが消えてきました
だから我々には疑問がある
疑いがある 理由はよくわからないからなんです
宇宙はどう始まったかと
地球はどうやって よくわからないんです
生命って何なのか いまだに科学的には生命ライフというもののデフィニションを定義することはできないんです
他 物質を定義できます
何でも科学はもう定義から定義
定義から定義と つまり我々は How do you define the life? 大変にも生命というものは定義できません
仏教は生命を定義してから始まるんです
だから科学より進んでいるんです
それで私たちはこの真理知らないんだから
疑いがあって 疑いがあって
どうでしょう どうでしょう
どうしてどうなっているのかと
いつでも心は不満で そうすると何かにしがみつく
これが事実だ これが事実だ
あの人の言っていることは真理だ
この人の言っていることは真理だとかね
これ走り回っちゃう すべてから解放されるんだと
現象がこのように現れて
このように消えるのをキャッチした
それからお釈迦様は すべての現象がどうやって消えていくのかと
因果法則をまた再び逆順で観察する
逆順で観察するとまた喜びになるんですね
それはこのように唱えるんです
ヤダウェーパアトゥバワンティダンマアタピノジャヤトブラフマナッサアタッサカンカワカヤンティサンバヤトカヤンパッチヤナンアウェディ
おなじみなんですが 修行者が一生懸命
修行者っていうのはお釈迦様のこと
一生懸命現象を観察すると
現象のありのままの姿があらわになる
見えてくる それで この現象はなんで消えるのか
なんで消えるのか なんで消えるのか
この消える 消えるプログラム
滅のプログラム を見えてくる
そうすると心が解脱に達してて
安穏を感じるんだと で
それでお釈迦様が最初にすべて終わりましたと悟りましたと
長い長い間頑張ったことは
生命が探し求めた 欲しがった真理をやっと発見して
ご自分が体験しましたと
また喜びの言葉を語るんです
ヤダハヴェーカトゥバワンティダンマアタピノジャヤトブラフマナッサ
ヴィドゥーパヤンティンタティマーラセーナン
スリヨウヴァーサヤンタリッカン
修行者が お釈迦様が必死で精進して観察していくと
すべての現象があらわになるんだと
その時 ヴィドゥーパヤンマーラセーナン
悪魔の軍隊すべて粉々に壊れるんだと
悪魔の軍隊っていうのは宗教的な悪者じゃないんです
我々に苦しみを司る いくら頑張っても苦しみしか生まれてこない
この心にある欠陥なんですね
要するに煩悩なんです
粉々に消えてしまいます
心が清らかになって輝くんだと
たとえがあります 太陽が現れると
すべての世界が光り輝くように
だから悟りっていうのは
暗い心に太陽が現れて
隅から隅まで智慧の光が現れたことなんですね
そういうわけで 皆様もお釈迦様の無量の功徳によって
お釈迦様の偉大な智慧によって
皆様にも幸福がありますようにと誓願いたします
特にこのお祭りを昨日からね
昨日もやりましたし 教会の我々の仲間の方々はね
仏教の場合はみんな兄弟ですからね
いや 私は先輩ですけどね
兄弟だからって甘く見ない方がいい
[笑い]で みんな我々兄弟で
すごくお互いに協力し合って
すごい苦労したんだけど
楽しいんですよ みんなと一緒にね
一つの家族として歩んで
これも朝早くこういう風に準備をして
ウェーサーカ祭りのことを行いました
それからお布施 あの功徳を回向したい方々もいらっしゃいまして
昼ご飯のお弁当の布施はね
長いゆ-ゆ-ゆりこですね
長いゆりこさんが 去年も長いゆりこさんでしたけどもね
皆様の弁当の またお釈迦様の布施などなどをお布施いたします
それから最後に皆様に配る清水の布施はアンド
アンドサツミ様でございます
これは名前だけれど 他の方々も一生懸命お布施していますからね
皆様にブッダのことを念じて
真理のことを念じて 日本の国の世界の人々の幸福を願って
この行ったこの布施の功徳によって幸福でありますように
すべての希望が叶えられますように
日々心が清らかに清らかになりますように
一切の煩悩がなくなって
解脱涅槃に達することができますようにと誓願いたしまして
私の話を終了します  サッ
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものの悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
生きとし生けるものの願いごとが叶えられますように
生きとし生けるものにも
悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生ける 幸せでありますように
はい ありがとうございます
あのちょっと言霊ですけど
ウェーサーカマッスルというのは本当にお祭りです
あの すごく我々は真剣に行いますが
あの大体スリランカでは結構どんちゃん騒ぎやったり
音楽をやったり 歌ったり踊ったり
もう何でもやってます
ですから 皆さんは気楽に楽しく
最大のね 心を清らかにするお祭りということで
楽しく一日過ごしてください
真剣にならなくても結構です
はい ありがとうございます
はい では今日の極端な難しい話になります
えーとですね お釈迦様のお誕生日とブッダになったあの成就ですね
それを祝福する祝いする日で
まあ一応お釈迦様からの一言葉がないと思います
あていただけね 真剣に喜んでいたっていうのね
それでお釈迦様はなかなか喋ってくれませんだからお釈迦様は一応全部お話して終わりましたからね
そういうわけで 今 すごい今日はものすごい難しくなるかもしれませんだけどね
お釈迦様からの言葉として聞いてみてください
このお話はいろんな方法でとって
とことんとことん勉強してみてください
そうすると すごい簡単に解脱の方法を理解できると思います
子供たちもいろいろいらっしゃいますけど
今日はちょっと子供たちに理解できるように教えることは難しいかも
でも子供たちだけで喋れば
この内容を喋れますよ
子供と大人が混じっちゃうと難しい
で このこの前のスライドでね
オープニングスライドで私はこのちょっと出してみて
ジャッジメント審判というタイトル人様でそういうタイトルにしたんですね
これがキーワードでポイントなんですね
審判 そこでこの相対性を発見しないと人は無明を破れない
だから無明という話 仏教でありまして
今日は答え 一つの答えを出します
相対性を破りましょうと
それでもわからないんですね
はい わからないまま置いておきましょう
この審判する 判断するっていうところからちょっと考えてみましょう
で はい で 何を言おうかというと
ヤサス長老も聞いたんで
今日は何ですか？タイトルは
超難しいんだと タイトルは言えませんと
タイトルはサンマディティなんですね
正見なんです なんだこれ
超難しいですか？と思うでしょう
この正見というのは 解脱の
いわゆるブッダが教える人間が解脱に悟らなくちゃいけない
このサマ 入り口 正見 それから入ったらそちら側の解脱なんですね
そこで正見というと 正見邪見というまた相対的なことが出てくるんですね
相対的なそういうものなんですよ
高い 低い 白い 黒い ね あったかい
冷たい そういう風に この対立的な単語で相対世界が成り立つんですよ
必ず対立でなくてもいいんです
例えばよりという言葉あるんですね
これはより明るい というと相対的なんですね
あなたって比較的に若いですねとかね
言うと それも相対的な意味で
私たちはいつでもそういう相対的な世界でいるんですね
そこでこの対立 相対 だからこの英語の単語言っちゃっとまずいね （
笑）こういうあのディレクトオポジットというね
ディレクトオポジットリレーティビティあるんですね
だからディレクトオポジットならないリレーティビティもありますね
シミラーということでね
いろいろあります そんなこと喋っちゃうとなんかわけがわからなくなりますから
やめます とにかく対立的に見たら
正見だったら邪見もあるんじゃないかな
邪見っていうのは 仏教は自分たちだけ正見で
他の宗教は邪見だと言っちゃって
なんだこれはって思うでしょ
そんな意味ではないんです
仏教は この正見邪見っていうのは
迷信 信仰 感情 伝統 文化
習慣などから作る客観的なデータを気にしない
無視する 自由を妨げる
足かせ 足かせになるものなんですね
全部一気に書いてしまったんです
まあ時間短かもしれない時間なんですね
邪見だったら迷信で邪見が生まれる
信仰で邪見が生まれる
だから邪見という名前だけ
信仰から考えた見解は邪見なんですね
あるいは伝統 伝統的にはこういう考えだよとね
だからまあそれもちょっと正見にはならないんですね
文化的にも我々の考え方にあってね
はい そういうこと あまり客観的なデータは気にしない
例えば豆腐食べる場合は何をかける？平安とか
お醤油かける なんでマヨネーズかけないんですかね？かけてみて食べられます
マヨネーズ嫌だったらタバスコでもかけてみたら？言っちゃうとなんだかみんな笑っちゃいますね
え？豆腐にタバスコかける？なんだこれは
タバスコはピザにかけますけどね
とかね スパゲッティにかけますけどとか
それっていうのは なんでしょうかね
だからあれ 伝統的な決まりでしょ
私も試してみたんですよ
豆腐にちょびっとお醤油かけて食べて
まあ悪くはないね ある日
あのサラダにかけるゴマドレッシングありますね
あれ私は一応好きなんですからね
ゴマドレッシングをかけてみたんです
まあ結構ですね まずくなったわけじゃないんです
そこでさらに調子に乗り上がっちゃって
豆腐に我々のインドスリランカ風の唐辛子の漬物あるんですよ
あの日本でもチャイニーズチリペーストという名前で売ってますけどね
じゃああれかけたらどうですか？とかけてみたんです
結局いけるんです それ
だからこの でもなかなか勇気が出てこないんですね
それは伝統にちょっと足を引っ張られているんですね
それでこの客観的なデータ見ないんですね
あまり それを邪見というんですね
そこで邪見になったら自由がなくなるんです
別に他の宗教の悪口言ってるわけじゃないんです
自分には思考の自由がなかったら
自分には正見がないんです
はい 次の続きます これで邪見だから悩み
苦しみが生まれるんです
邪見っていうのは正見の反対だから
これ間違った見解 間違った見解だったら間違った結果生まれるでしょう
だから我々何やってもうまくいかなかったら
あれは正見でやってないんですね
間違った見解で 若い子は結婚しようかなと結婚相手選んだ
選んで結婚してきたら間違ったと後から気づくんですね
だったら最初からあなたの判断は邪見に基づいた判断でしたよと言えるんですね
だから後からわかっても意味がないんだから
最初から悪から正見を作った方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
その中でも一番いい大事なところは
この二行目である 邪見にしがみつくと成長が止まり堕落する
自分に意見があって構いませんだけど
この意見にしがみつかないでください
例えば豆腐食べると塩
塩じゃなくてお醤油かけてください
これは意見だけで これに決まった
他 他のものと絶対組み合わせないこと
これはもう決まり おかしいことをやって言っちゃうとアウトなんですね
しがみつく必要ないんです
まあ常識的には豆腐にはお醤油をかける
あなたシロップかけたいればどうしようとか
あんたシロップかけて食べると美味しい
美味しいだったらどうぞどうぞ
もう一人はシロップじゃなくてメンタルシロップありますね
メンタルシロップ すごく豆腐と合います
合うんだったらいいじゃない
それで これ日本文化を侵しているとかね
和食文化は何やってるの
この人は とかね これまで大事に守られてきた食文化をね
そこが仏教はちょっとアウトとするんですね
意見にしがみつく 意見にしがみついちゃうと新しい発見できないんです
開拓できないんです 進むことはできないんです
だから そこが一番危険なポイントなんですね
そこで反対に 正見というのは世間一般的に認められる考えになる
本当は まあ順番で説明しているんだけど
ちょっとこれ捨てて 全部捨てて自由に喋ろうかなと思ったんですね
これはちょっとすごい勢いで作ったんだから
ちょっと難しくなっちゃったんですね
今の正見について語ります
正見というのは この まず世間一般的に正しいと認める大体の対象が認めるものもある程度で正見なんですね
それから皆仲良く調和を保って生きられる
比較的に幸福に生きられる
それだったら正見ですね
みんな仲良くいられますよ
こんな考えだったらみんな仲良くなれる
だったらその考えがいいんです
こういう考えで生きてみれば
結構楽しくなります 人生楽になります
だったらその考えはまあいい考えですね
それに正見と言った方がいいんじゃない？まず
だから正見邪見というのは
お釈迦様が人を馬鹿にするためにおっしゃったわけじゃないんです
ここは理解してくれると
人間が幸福になる 幸せになる
穏やかになる 仲良くなる
平和になる考えが正見です
人間がダメージになる
喧嘩になる 争い 戦いになる
不幸に陥る そういう思考は
考えは邪見であると だから私たちは正見邪見決める場合は
そういう風に決めるんです
あなた信じている神様は名前なんですかっていうことで関係ないんです
世間はそうなんです 私はアッラーという神様を信仰している
あなたの神様は イエホワ
あんた邪教 異端者 あっち行ってください
それじゃないんです 自分が信仰する神様の名前がアッラーであろうか
イエホワであろうか えーと
安土新太郎であろうが別にいいんです
それは その考えで自分が幸せになるなら
自分が幸福になっているならば
まあいいんじゃない はい
それからこの実践に行きます
どうやって正見実践するのか
なんで正見にこんなにことわるくなるかというと
正見が入り口なんです
ブッダの世界 解脱の世界
入り口無視して入らないでしょ
他入るところないのです
では 今から我々は正見の人間になろうではないか
どうやってなるのかというと
実践一 世間の善悪を認める
あんまり自分自身で我を張らないで
世の中の人々はこれが悪いことですよ
これがいいことですよ
こうした方がいいんだよとかね
大体大人やら上の人やら
まあ本読んだら 本の中やら物語
あの神話物語を読んでみても
なんか良い生き方と悪い生き方
シンデレラ物語だってもね
やっぱり人いじめとならんとかね
なんとなくありますね
そういう風に この世間に一般的に言われている善悪を認める
これで難しくない それから道徳を守る
世間に認められる常識的な人間になる
道徳ってやって この偉そうなことじゃない
道徳っていうのはね 道徳っていうのは普通に正しい生き方なんですよ
人の家に入るところは靴を脱ぐとか
そんな難しいことじゃないでしょ
日本人同士ではお辞儀をして挨拶する
相手がヨーロッパ人だったら
じゃあ手を出して握手してみる
そんな感じで まあ普通に正しい生き方は道徳なんです
いるんですよ この普通な常識的な生き方が嫌で嫌で
なんか野蛮人みたいに生活しようと
俺が嫌いだということでね
俺が靴脱ぎたくないんだから
あなたの家に入りませんとかね
そうすると調和が崩しちゃうんですね
崩れてしまいます そしてその人はなんか道徳的じゃないんですね
だから道徳を守るぐらい心
柔軟性があったら 道徳はどの宗教でもいいんです
別に であったら まあなんとなく正見に近いんですね
それから目上の先輩の
知識人の 理性のある人の考えを参考にする
自分勝手に判断しないで
目上の人の意見を聞いてみて
先輩の考えを聞いてみて
知識人の意見も聞いてみて
うーん だからどうしようと自分で判断すれば
あの人もこう言ってるし
この人もこう言ってるし
じゃあ仕方がないね じゃあこうしましょう
その優しさ この優しさなんですね
かっこいいんですよ 正見
感情より理解能力を優先する
我々はだいたい感情で生きているんだからね
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみで これは頑張って感情をちょっと抑えましょう
何か判断するとき 何か人と喋るとき
何かやるときは理性でやりましょう
そうすると なんか正見にの人間になってるんですね
実践二に行きます 行為に結果が必ずとあると理解する
私はこの この膨大な この仏教のね
もうテキストにあるものをぎゅっと縮めたんです
この正見についてものすごい語りしてるんです
だからぎゅっとこれ縮められないのかと考えちゃったんです
で 実践二ですね 行為に結果が必ずあると理解する
皆様方は正見になりたければ
いたって簡単 行為に結果がある
これで迷信？じゃないでしょ
行為に結果がある 大体私は両手を激しく合わせる
これ行為でしょ 音が出ます
こうやって激しく手を合わせるから
これ行為の結果 これは否定しちゃうともう話にならないね
だから人はこれ真剣であってほしい
なぜなら面白いんですよ
人間というのは 行為に結果というのは当たり前と言いつつも
認めないところは結構あるんですよ
例えばね 自分の息子がね
乱暴にオートバイに乗ってね
これでもう大怪我をして
もしかするともう生涯なんか問題あるような体になっちゃう
それでお母さん それを認めたくない
元気で歩いていた 元気で走り回っていた息子が車椅子になっちゃう
これは認めたくないね
まだ若いし 結婚もしていないし
そこで正見からずれちゃうんです
自分の可愛い息子がね
もう二十歳ごろで乱暴な運転で
オートバイでね もう事故っちゃって車椅子になったと
認めたくないんだけど
認めてください 行為の結果です
どうしようもない だから行為に出てくる結果が良いものである
悪いものであるか それに文句言う権利がないんです
行為の結果だ それだけ
例えば 人がなんか乱暴で悪口を言ったら
相手に殴られた 認めてください
仕方がないんです 自分の行為に適切な結果が出ます
我々が悪いことをしても
悪い結果は嫌だ これはと文句を言うんだから
邪見というものなんです
それが邪見なんです 例えば会社のお金をちょっと横領する
バレない 一年 一ヶ月間も二ヶ月もやって
一年もやって ちょこちょこちょこちょこ
そうすると給料以外金が入るんだから
これ奥さんにバレたら困りますから
この余分なお金で賭け事やらいろんなことやったりで遊んでる
奥さんさえ気づかない
でも一年になってくると計算取るんだから
会計の方でね ちょっとなんかバランスが崩れていて
どういうことか調べるとバレちゃうんだよ
バレたから その結果に対してすごい腹が立って
何だこれはとかね 奥さんに文句
私はここまで真面目に仕事をしているのに
会社の問題を私に整備しようとしてるんだよと
これはもう仕方がない
行為に結果が出る 受け止めるしかないんです
そんな立派な人間になったら
もう正見です それだけ足らない
だからこういうに結果があるんだから
善と悪とは何なのかと勉強しましょう
そうすると我々に善行為を選べない
選べます 勉強していないとこういうの結果あるんだからって行動する
そうすると良い結果も悪い結果もバラバラ出てくる
面倒くさいでしょ それだったらこういうの結果がある
次 私は善と悪を学んでみる
学んでみて 良い結果期待して善行為をする
それで正見なんです それからもっと簡単な方法あります
親孝行 社会に貢献する
優れた人間になるようにと努力する
財産より精神の清らかさを大事だと思う
そういう人格を変えることで
我々は正見の人間になっていくんだよ
じわじわじわじわ で 早く飛ばさないと次のサイトに行きます
三 で レベルアップします
今言ったのは世間的に正見
もうちょっとレベルアップします
ブッダの教えを学ぶ すごいレベルの高い正見になります
よく理解して納得いくように励む
ブッダの説かれた指導に従って生きる
他人の意見を学ぶとき
主観感情ではなく理性を使う
そこで四つの項目があります
これ結構アドバンスレベルです
まあちょっと高いレベルなんです
なんかパクっちゃうんですね
自分で発見するのは面倒くさい
もうできない だからブッダの教えを学んで
学んで ブッダの知恵をパクっていいんです
お釈迦様がOKと言ってるんです
お釈迦様はコピーライト持ってないんです
だからこちら正見で生きていきたい
しっかり正しいことをやって
しっかり幸せになりたい
だったらお釈迦様の教えを盗んじゃえばいいんじゃない？これすごい良いことを教えてるんですね
それで教え盗んだだけでは役に立たない
自分で理解するんです
そうすると役に立ちますね
それからでも自分に判断できない
それ人生変える勇気がない
それだったら まあお釈迦様が言ったことをやる
一応いいかな お釈迦様これやめなさいと言ったんだから
やめたと お釈迦様これやりなさい
はい 言われたらやります
そうすると楽チンで正見に入っていくんです
それでも世界で生きている場合は
友達の話を聞かなくちゃいけない
親の話を聞かなくちゃいけない
会社の上司の話を聞かなくちゃいけない
人の話を聞かなくちゃいけないんです
時々玄関のピンポン鳴らして
あら 何ちゅう神様信じているんですか？となんか話しかけてくる場合もあります
こう話を聞かなくてはいけない
この間 最近私の家にも人が来ましたけど
丁寧でしたけど あのジェホバの証人の方々がね
で パンフレットかなんて置いて
あの集まりがありますから
おせじから相手側はすごい丁寧でしたから
はい よくわかりました
時間があったら私も来ますよ
約束したけど その日が私は大阪に行かなくちゃいかなかったんですね
面白いポイントあったんです
イエス様の誕生日は4月12日やと
あれ？私たちの花祭りを奪ってるんじゃないか
まあいいです 別に いわゆる 12月25日ではない
とにかく集まりに行きたかったんです
私は スケジュールがあれでね
そこで人の話を聞く場合は
お前の考え間違ってるとかね
なんでそんなこと言うのか
そんなことで犬猫みたいに考えたらかっこ悪い
感情を置いておいて 理性で
なるほどなるほど なんでそう言うの？理由は何ですか？という風に理性で聞けばかっこいいんですよ
だから正見生き方がすごいかっこいい生き方なんですね
じゃあ実際四に行きましょうか
もっと難しくなる 因果法則をできる範囲で理解してみる
因果法則とはブッダの教えです
だから別に仏教という宗教の匂いはないんです
因果ですからね だからあの因果法則をできる範囲で理解できるし
なぜできる範囲かというと
因果法則というのは膨大な理論ですよ
全宇宙のすべてのついて分かっているものなんですね
だからその中で自分の人生に関わる
パートだけ切り抜いて学べばいいんです
すべてのものは要らないです
自分の人生に関係ある因果法則だけ切り抜いて学んでみる
それから もう一つありますね
すべての現象は因縁によって生じて消えるものであるという観点で生きる
生きる ある人生哲学 まあ何でも因縁によって現れるんだと
いろいろ社会は変わるでしょ
いろいろ原因があってこうなってるんだとかね
原因はまあこういうことじゃないとかね
それでいろいろ流行り変わったりするしね
まあそれまた原因によってこれ変わりますよ
世の中を見てみると そういうことわかるでしょ
だからいつでも自分のプライベートな哲学として
物事は因縁によって生まれ
因縁によって消える 今度の流行りは黄色の服やと言ったら
ああ そうですか まあ前はこういう色でしたからね
なんとかわかります でもそれも 1ヶ月とか 2ヶ月とかいないで
これも変わるでしょう
もう一つ お釈迦様に説かれた四聖諦
苦集滅道という これ勉強すれば
これだったら正見そのもの
はい これで俗世間的で一般の方々に理解できる正見が終わる
次開いてみてください
高度な出世間の修行 信仰と知識を超える道
これは難しいね 私はこれを別に省略します
スライドにあまりこだわらないで
とにかく次のスライドに行ってみましょうか
で スライドに関係なく喋ります
この正見邪見との場合は
見という言葉から見の見解なんです
英語ではビューポイントなんです
それに正か邪か入れるだけ
ビューポイント ビューポイントっていうのは私に見える見方
仕方がない 皆様にも目があるんだけど
皆様の見方は私に見えませんね
私に私の目で見える 私の目で見て
私はビューポイント見解を作る
それが正しいかないか
これは別な話 そこで仕方がなく
例えば皆様がこちらにお釈迦様の前に飾っている花
見ましょうか 皆様に目あるんだから
皆様にも見える じゃあご意見はなんでしょうか？聞きましょうか
だから言葉のハンディがあるんだけど
ご意見は一人一人違うんです
あの 誤意見だからね 間違ってる意見ですけどね
敬語じゃないんです で
だからこちらに飾ってる花で
今の見え方と照明 今消してるんだからね
照明つけたらまた見解が変わるでしょ
そこでが問題なんですよ
人に聞けば 種類 の意見
人に聞けば種類 の意見
ということは 世の中を観察すると
見解っていうのは無限にある
ひどいもんです  こちらテーブルの上に
例えば猫の置物を置きましょう
猫の置物を置いて では
あなたの意見は？出てくるは出てくるは
みんないろんな意見 たまたま言葉似ているんですよ
例えば日本の招き猫あるでしょ
これは日本人見たらある見解と招き猫の文明文化がない西洋人とかね
他の国々の人々見たら
え？なんで猫はこうやってるんだ
変じゃない？と思うでしょ
猫ってこういう風にいることに
あるいはこういう風にやった方が可愛いでしょう
猫はこういうことやりますからね
ではなくて これはやりませんね
いくらなんでも でも あのポーズの猫は日本だったら
まああれは招き猫やとかね
まあなんか知ったつもりはする
でもその置物も見る見る人が自分の見解を持っている
同じ家族でおばあちゃんが招き猫にするての意見
おじいさんの意見 お父さんのお母さんの意見と子供の意見がそれぞれバラバラです
例えばおじいさんがすごい自分が尊敬する大事な先生から師匠からお土産としてもらった招き猫
招き猫っていいんですね
あの 招き猫で英語の言葉ありますかね
それって今作りたくなっちゃった
calling キャットとかインワイティングキャットとかね
結構実はちょっとおかしいね
で そうするとおじいさんにとっては
別な見解 孫から見て古くせくさいとね
もう年季が働いているんだから
いやいや気分 気持ち悪い
この孫の意見 そういうことで
一つの現象オブジェクトを入れておいて
人間に聞けば聞くほど見解が違う
人間だけじゃないんですよ
自分の家で飼っている猫ちゃんも招き猫を見えますよ
猫がどんな見解を持ってるんですかね
あれ 俺と似てると思う？わかりませんね
こんなの 猫は猫の顔形知らないからね
猫は鏡で自分を見て ちょっとひげをちょっとやらないんですよ
だってゴートミの猫はあのちょっと茶色っぽいでしょ
自分の色なんですね 私は茶色の衣着て事務所に行くとすごい機嫌が悪い
あの色 あの色嫌いみたい
この衣を着ていると 膝の上に寝ようかなとかね
この色好きなんですね
私は毎日文句言わない
お前いるでしょ これはとか
これじゃなかったら茶色の衣ね
なんで嫌がるの？と聞いてくれないんですね
だから あのゴートミの何さんでしたっけ？ナミちゃん
おかしい おかしくはないんだけど
なんかそういう見解ですよ
自分の体の色は自分の好みじゃない
自分の目で見えると派手に見えるこの色が好みです
だから犬猫にも見解あるんです
その見解の中 誰が正しい？これが問題
見解にはきりがないんです
ビューポイントというものにはきりがないんです
人に納豆食べさせて 感想を書いてくださいと言ったら
みんなコピーペーストに書くと思う？書かない
それぞれ自分の感想が違うんです
ここでなんか問題あるんですね
私は正直で自分の見解を書いた
例えば納豆まずい 臭いと
私が書きます 私は嘘をついているわけじゃない
私の経験を言っている
素直 隣の人は納豆って素晴らしい
美味しかったわとか 大きさちょうどよくて
硬さもちょうどよくて
あれやこれやとかね そこで自分のあったかいご飯にはものすごくピッタシあって
素晴らしいご飯でしたってその人は書く
その人も正直に書くんですね
どうすればいいんだ これ
納豆はすごくまずいという人と臭くてまずいと
もう一人が臭いではない
まずいと もう一人が味はまあまあですけど
匂いはね あれはごめんよと
いろんな見解変わるでしょ
みんな正直に語ってる
みんな嘘を言ってるわけじゃない
ではどういうこと？みんな本当のことを言ってるのに
意見まとめてみたら一つもまとめないんです
これが問題です これが問題です
では 仏教的に答えを出します
ビューポイント見解と言ったら
これは無数にあり得る
それからスーッと変わる
朝 納豆まずいと 匂いは気に入らないと言った人は
夜になったらそういうことはないと言うんですよ
匂いは別にそんな大丈夫
同じ人も違う見解に見解に変わるんです
これは皆様経験しているでしょ？かつてすごい
あの人は本当にいい人と言った人は
それからもう絶対あの人とはもう付き合いたくない
敵だという場合あるでしょ
あの人はちょっと態度がでっかくてね
私の好みじゃないと言って非難していた人が
やがてすごく仲良し友達になってるとかね
こういう変化っていうのは
我々は毎日経験しているんです
これが仏教的な答え 見解は無数に現れる
終わりがない しかし 一つも正解ではありません
正解 出したらそれがそれで終わる
問題は納豆はいかがでしょうかっていうことには正解はない
だから様々な意見の間ですごいトラブルが起こる
そのような そのような事実
例えば納豆の匂いは我慢できないということは
その人にとって事実です
その人によって真理です
納豆大好きな人から見れば
これは認めるわけにはいきません
しかし 納豆大好きということは
その人の事実です その人にとっては真理です
じゃあどうすればいいですか？そこでお釈迦様は使っている言葉がありまして
このパーシャル 英語で言えば
いわゆる偏見なんです
偏見と言うとなんか仏教的
日本語的になんかけなしてるような気がします
けど そうじゃないんです
偏っていうのは偏見の片っ方というね
パーシャル パーシャルはちょっと日本語の単語で出てこなかったんですね
パーシャルという いわゆる全体的に真理ではないんだけど
部分的に 日本的にわかりやすいのは
まああなたの立場から見れば納豆美味しいんですよ
あなたの立場から見れば納豆まずいですよ
そこで破片 真理の破片 2つあるんだけど
真理はできてないんですね
これ破片無限にあるんだから
この破片集めて集めて集めて組み立てても全体の意見は出てこないです
これは正見の世界なんです
正見を学ぶ時はそれを学ばなくちゃいけないんです
これをわかった時点で
皆様すごい立派な人間ですよ
すごく楽に生きてられます
人間の意見には困りません
人間の考え方には困りません
人間の生活習慣に困りません
なぜかというと あ その人の立場から見れば
まあそんなもんです 例えば
自分が親のことを恨んでるんだよという人がいる
その人の立場から見れば
よくわかります で 親から見れば
悲しがってるんですね
なんでうちの子供はわがままで乱暴でいい人間になってほしいんだけどとかね
親の立場から見れば それはそれでその通り
だからもうどうしようもないでしょ
この世の中 どうしようもない
この見解の問題 それで見解とは偏見です
パーシャルトゥルー パーシャルという単語は
この PART パーという部分という言葉がありますね
それは形容詞にするんで
パーシャルという だから日本語は偏見なんです
偏っていうのは部分ですからね
断片という意味なんですね
単純に納豆はいかがでしょうか？という問いについてでも
偏見が無数にあるんだから
偏見をまとめて組み立てても組み立てても全体像が出てこない
だって組み立てないでしょ
納豆美味しいという部品取ったり
まずいというのも取られませんからね
その場合 もう一つ仏教的な言葉がありまして
この首の最初のこの真理の 2つの真理って条件付き
これ今喋ったのは条件付きの真理なんです
嘘じゃないんです えら取ってまずいという人は嘘をついてないんです
納豆は大好き 美味しくてたまらないという人も嘘をついてない
どちらでも正しいか間違っている
そんな話を置いておきましょう
この子の条件によって
そういう結論に達するんだと
これわかれば立派な人間にならない？喧嘩しないで生きてられますよ
大体みんな感情的であの人をこう言っただから嫌だなんて
なんだこりゃと 条件でそうなるだけ
あなたの見方から見れば
それはまあ あの人がすごい態度が悪いかもしれませんだけど
まあその人の立場から見れば
そんなもん 考えて 例えばお前って本当にバカですねって言われた
言われて なんで私にそんなことを言うのかとかね
とっても怒って言った人に聞いてみた
まあただ楽しくて言っただけですけど
そうするとどうしますかね
バカよ あんた そういうわけで
私たちの知識 私たちの考え
すべて偏見です だって私に見えた世界だから
それは隣の人の意見と合わないんです
気をつけてください 結婚しても夫婦は同じ見解にはなりません
自分が産んだ産んだ子供がお母さんと同じ意見にはなりません
だって自分が産んだ子供の子供の目があるんだから
子供の耳があるんだから
子供の鼻があるんだから
お母さんの鼻とは見えないでしょ
時々パン大好きなのお母さんに小麦粉アレルギー反応を持ってる子供が生まれるんだから
仕方がない はい 今日は理解しました
私の知識は一切すべて偏見である
偏見というのは破片 この破片をまとめて全体像を作れます
世の中これやろうとしているんです
無理です それでは真理にたどらないんです
お釈迦様だけ答えを見つけたんですね
次の真理っていうのは
あの 何て言ったっけ？えーと
条件に依存しない もう仕方がない
その場合 個人好みは関係ない
好きに決まります 人の見解によって変わらない
変えられない事実です
私はよく言っているのは
れっちくが満了 これは人の見解じゃないね
仕方がない 私の好みでこれ変えることはできません
それから仏教的な例を出すと
一切現象は無常です あなたどう思ったって勝手にしなさいと
時々いるんですよ 私は絶対死にたくないんだ
どうぞあなたの偏見は自由に持ってください
でも死にます 人の主観関係ない
一切は無常ということには
それは偏見ではない それは正見です
誰にだってその結論に達しなくちゃいけない
誰にだってどんな方法で地球のね
この我々が生きている
この大地の形を調べること
これは丸いということになるんですよ
いくら頑張っても これ平らでしょ
円形楕円形でしょとかね
あるいはあの 蜂が倒れたら無限と言うでしょ
もう倒れた無限の形ですけど
これは無理 ここで仏教の人々は
この条件付きで自分に見える真理と
条件に関係なく見える真理
二つを発見しているのです
人は条件付きの真理の
えーと 何でしたっけね
次元で生きているんです
それでかわいそうで 我々はこの条件に依存しない真理で生きていないんです
我々は条件付きの真理の世界で生きている
だからこれは問題だと
これはもうお釈迦様は解決しなくちゃいけないと思っていたんです
みんな真理だ 事実だ これこそ正しいんだ
これこそ正しいんだとかね
争っているんだと やめなさい
これ全部条件付きの真理だよ
だからお釈迦様は哲学的にこう言うんです
我は正しい 他は間違っていると言ったことほど間違っている言葉がないんだ
イダメヤワサッチャンモーガマニャンパーリコティ
そのままあるんです イダメヤワサッチャン
ワッダイプレイクイストオンリートゥルース
私が言うことだけ真理である
モーガンマニャン 他の人々の考えはすべて無から無駄
意味がない これ インドの宗教家がそんなことで喧嘩している
お釈迦様から見れば たくさん宗教が現れるのは当たり前のこと
ある人の子供が病気になって
この親が悲しくて川のところに座って川を見ながら
ああ 子供が早く病気治った方がいいのにねとかね
あいつはかわいそうだなとかね
と悩んでいる 川を見ながら落ち着きたいんです
そこで家に戻る 夜になったら戻ってみると
子供の状況は良くないという
その人の宗教を作ります
まさかあの川を守っていた神が神様がいたんじゃない？あの神様が私の悩みを読んで
私の子供を治してくれた
では今日から川を拝みますと
同相自由 いい 許すしかないでしょ
もう一人の人の子供が病気になったところで
その人は全部嫌で 山に上がって崖を登る
登って一番高いところに座って周りを見ながら
はぁ どうかなとか うちの子は助かるかなとかね
悩んで それで遅くなって降りてきて
やっぱり子供の調子がいいんですね
いくら え？もしかすると
あの山に神様がいて 私の気持ちわかったでしょ
ありがたい ありがたい
山を拝みますよ 一人が川を拝み
一人が山を拝む どうすればいい？こっちくらい
どちらでも正しくないんです
だから仏教から見れば
みんな宗教を作るのはもう当たり前の話
全くないんです 全て偏見だからね
その人に見えた世界だから
しかし お釈迦様の推薦は条件に頼らない真理で生きてみなさい
それが真理の道 その難しくない
例えば全ては無常 真理です
そこで生きている だからそこを先にいく方と違います
驚かない この人 子供が病気になったら
まあ僕になってくるとちょっと調子が良くなっている
だって無常だから 病気
それなりの原因があったでしょう
うん はい 次の財布は英語の単語を見てしまいましたけど
パーシャルというね 見解の特色
自分の立場から達した結論
判断は見解です 一つのこと
柄についていくらでも見解を作ることができます
条件が導く判断なので
正否って正しい間違っている決定はできません
えーと 仏教はパッキャーカサパーシャクと言いますが
日本語では偏見と言うでしょうね
そこまで説明しました
はい 次 次のページに行きます
決めなくとは何でも始まらないっていうね
この生きるためには判断しなくてはいけない
どうしてあんた昼何食べる？ご飯にする？ラーメンにする
パンにする サンドイッチにする
あるいはドーナツ ドーナツにする
なんだかね サンドイッチでもどんなサンドイッチにすると
決めないと動かない そういうわけで
我々にとっては判断しなくちゃいけない
そこで判断するときは
ものの見事に偏見で判断する
そういうわけで この人は自分の
まず自分の偏見で判断したいんですね
こんな判断して結構失敗したんだから
人の意見も聞く こういうことなんですけど
あんたどう思う？とかね
私は何〇〇さんと結婚したいと思ってはいるんだけど
あんたどう思う？って人に聞くんです
時々お母さんが お母さん
あの人のことどう思う？とかね
自分が気に入った人についてお母さんに聞いたら
お母さんわかる？でも聞いた方が結構真面目ですね
なんか変な世界ですよ
だから我々は自分一人で判断したらまずい結果になっちゃったんだから
人に聞くでしょうね 聞いたってもうこんな感じです
だから ダメですよ もともとからの人生は
わがままで判断してもダメ
絶対うまくいかない では
人の意見を聞いてみたら？うまくいかない
だからダメです 偏見で判断して生きてるんですよ
はい 次のスライドで この中もうわかったでしょ？我々の生き方はもうなんかちょっと危ない
ブッダの智慧から見ると
今までしっかりやっていると思っていたんだけどね
これ偏見だらけの世界なんですね
偏見しか何もない世界なんです
だったら人の意見を聞きましょう
当てにならない だって参考にする
あっても偏見無数にあるんだから
一部しか参考しないでしょう
例えば あの人と結婚したければ
自分のお母さんに聞いて
自分のお父さんに聞いて
自分の兄弟に聞いてみて
それからその人のお母さんに聞いて
その人のお父さんに聞いてみて
その人の友達から調べて
小学校の友達から聞いて
中学校の友達からどこまでやる？どこまでやったっても正しい答えが来る？そういうことです
人生は その中でも根っこになるのは
私は正しいということなんです
これ暗記してください
我々はいつでも私は正しい
言わなくたって口でね
だって正しくない見解が現れないんですよ
例えば納豆食べた 食べたらまずくてガーッとなんかで吐きそうになっちゃった
なんでありがたいですか？こんな美味しい納豆って言える？言えません
だからその人は素直にこれまずいと言うんです
だからいつでも偏見と一緒に我は正しいという恐ろしい邪魔がついてる
はい そこを省略して次のスライドいきましょうか
十五番目のスライド 十六でしたか
十六ですね 判断と相対性を理解しましょう
もう判断しますね 我々
判断する時は相対的に判断します
良い悪い 善悪 気に入る
気に入らない 好き嫌い
認める 却下するなどの一切の判断
世界は相対的です 例えば
これは気に入らないよと言うでしょ
私 判断してるんです これは気に入ります
どうやって判断したの？こちらは
あ これは気に入った どうやって判断したのか
一般人はそれ調べないんですよ
ブッダは変ですね こういうところ調べるんです
誰も調べない これどうやってって
何か自分が気づかないんだけど
基準があるんです 例えば招き猫の置物
まだ持ってきましょう
招き猫の置物がある 私は私にはこれちょっと気に入らんなと言うんです
私には気に入らんって言ったら
どうやって言ったんですかね
そんなこと なんか自分の頭の中で気に入る招き猫の画像があるんですね
もしかするとその画像ないんです
ないのに これはちょっと気に入らない
だから気に入る 気に入らない
認める 認めない 良い悪い
善悪などなどの一切の
しかし 気をつけてください
判断なくして生きられない
生きるために呼吸と同じく判断が必要です
判断は何かに基準に合わせて良し悪しを決めるんです
この基準は何なのかで
自分でもわからないんですよ
例えばお母さんもね うちの子って可愛いなと判断する場合もあるし
こいつは本当にうるさくて迷惑だと判断する場合もあるんですね
なんだ この女はね 自分の子供に対して
ある時はなんでうちの子はこんなに可愛くてと判断したのに
別の時間で本当にうるさいこいつと
面倒くさいとか判断する
ということは 我々は気づかないあの基準がいい加減
いい加減です いつでもそうなんです
朝 例えばご飯と味噌と焼き魚でね
で ワンスプーン食べて
海苔もつけちゃってね
お新香一つで はぁ なんて幸せですか
と決めちゃう だったら死ぬまでそれ食えと
（笑）次の日 トーストにバターかけて卵を焼いて食ってるんじゃない？だから一番美味しい朝ごはん決める基準って何ですかね
ぐるぐる変わる 私の状況
ものすごくひどいんですよ
私はインド仏教系だから
あの牛乳系の食べ物は基本的に我々は食べないんです
昔 日本はすごく嫌がったでしょ
あのバター臭いという古い単語があったんですね
気持ち悪いって意味なんですね
気持ち悪いというのはバター
バターなんで みんな食べてますけどね
現代の日本人は だから昔の日本人にとっては
バターって  こんな匂いわとね
思ったでしょうね それで私はね
買い物行ったらヨーグルトを買うんです
店で見て ああ これは美味しそう
だから面倒くさい 料理も作らないでヨーグルト食べた方がいいでしょと思っちゃって
もう決めた 判断買った
買って冷蔵庫に入れて
これ開けるのは面倒くさい
今日はパス そこでカビが生えるまでパスになっちゃうんです
今もあるんです 自分で作ったやつ
買ったものじゃないんです
だから何やと この人生意義が
それで怖いことは 私たちは偉そうに判断して
善悪判断して生きていますけど
あの基準が あの尺度がいい加減ぐるぐる変わる
だから仏教の人は 人の意見なんかは全くの当てにしないんです
おかしい 一般人のレベルじゃないんです
ちょっと心理のレベルから見ると
全くも世間様が言うことは当てにならない
全部いい加減です だからお釈迦様はいつでも微笑んでるんです
お釈迦様のところに 「
私はこういう神様を信仰しています」と 「
うちの伝統で代々千年もこの信仰で決まったよ 」「
ああ そう 」お釈迦様は微笑んでるんです
当てにしない その方がよくない
人の判断と一緒に ああ
そうですか で終わっちゃう
あるおらま 若者ですけど
すごい知識人でね 天才的なるか二人でね
バラモン教ですけど バラモン教の修行方法が違うんですね
二人の伝統があるんだから
スクールが別二つ  ワーシティスクールでバラモンがディスクールと言いますけどもね
その二つのだから この喧嘩になっちゃうんだ
友達が 喧嘩になったらもう自分のスクールで
自分の先祖代々の学問でやってることをやりたいんです
向こうもそうでしょう
わしと我々のこの系列っていうのはすっごい古い
紀元前三千年頃まで古い
だから友達だからね もうものまねになっちゃって
これね ブッダに聞きましょう
あの人は結構もののこと知ってますよ
お釈迦様はこういう質問するんですね
わかった あなたの先生は？っていうのはお父さんなんですけどもね
この方法で梵天に生まれ変われるとね
自分が経験しているんだと言った
お父様が死んでないんだからね
言えないでしょ いえ 言ってない
ああ いいよです じゃあお父さんの師匠
いわゆるおじいちゃんですね
おじいさんがこの方法で必ず梵天に生まれ変わる
いわゆる天国に生きる
言った？言ってない これでだいたい魚目と魚
魚 ではヴェーダ聖典に書いた聖人たちだ
八人います あのテキスト書いてるけど
あの人々は言った 私はこれ経験している
これこそ事実  これ学者だからね
いい そんなことはないんだと
あると嘘を言えばお釈迦様は知っているんだからね
お釈迦様は全部暗記ですよ
なんて言うんです だからね
あのね あなた方はとね
ヴェーダ聖典そこ大変でも行ってないし
次の人も知らない だからまあいろんないい加減にしなさい
そんなにしがみつかなくてもいいんじゃないかという話でしょ
それで それでも僕が一人になりたい
ああそう じゃあ教えます
梵天ってどんな神？梵天はいつまでも慈しみのある神
だったらお前も慈しみを実践しなさい
そうすると同じ性質になるんだからね
同じものは一緒になりますよ
水と油が一緒にならないんだけど
水と水は一緒になります
油と油は一緒になります
ね だから自力さえやって
はい さようならと でお釈迦様たちが
だからお釈迦様が偏見なく正見だから
いつでも世間の人々を導くことはできるんですね
そこで私たちは決してこの相対性を理解しないんですね
例えば 私には今 この水を
このガラスに水を入れて飲むことはできる
今はちょっと喋って疲れているんだから
皆様は聞いてる 私ももっと疲れてると思ってるでしょうね
それは私の問題じゃないんだからね
で 私は水いっぱい飲んで
ああ 美味しいなと感じる
それって相対的でしょ
今くたくた疲れて 喋ると体の水分が出ていくんだから
血液の水分の濃度が下がっている
だから水がグッと体に入るんだ
美味しいと感じるんです
でも このペットボトルをガブガブ飲もうとすると
3口目までは美味しいんだけど
それから美味しくないね
それからまずくなってくる
なぜ？美味しい不味いの相対的で成り立つ
だから独立したアンコンディショナルではないんだ
条件に依存しない真理ではないんです
だから決してこの世の中で水は美味しいですか？不味いですかと聞いたっても
答えが成り立ちません
ご飯は美味しいですか？不味いですかと聞いたら答えがないんです
相対的で答えてください
朝食べたご飯は美味しかった
それだけ 普遍的な真理は言えない
でも自分が言うことを普遍的に持っていく人もいるでしょ
例えば ある人を見る ああ
かっこいい人だなと決めちゃう
ちょっと待ってください
それは相対的に決めたんです
また他の人を見てみると
この人の方がかっこいいや
あの人 あの人大丈夫 今すぐ変わったんだからね
なんで世界はそういうことであると認めない？それ事実でしょ
そうすると楽にならない？すごいかっこいい人間にならない
すごい頭のいい だからこれで皆様にあの人を見るとかっこいいと思うことは禁止じゃないんです
いいよ かっこいいと思ったのは
でもそれは相対的で その瞬間の気持ち以外なんでもない
次に別な人目に入ったら
やっぱりこの人の方がすごいかっこいいってことになっちゃうんです
あの人は？あの人は別にまあいいやと
そんなもんでしょう 人生
それその通りでありのままに理解していましょう
それでこの相対性の真理が
この馬鹿どもたちが正しいと思ってるでしょ
あの人かっこいい かっこいいで正しいんだよ
私には そこから間違える
そこから貪瞋痴が生まれる
そこからありとあらゆる煩悩が生まれる
えーと どこかにスライドがあったんだけど
えーと セブンティーン
十七 えーと 曖昧でどうでも良い基準を参照して判断するから
自分の判断を信じて ね
行動する人間の生き方が悩み苦しみを作り出します
これ 自作自演です 悩み苦しみ
だから乗り越えるんです
お釈迦様はそこでちょっとしたゲームやってるんです
苦しみとは生老病死である
愛別離苦があるんだ 怨憎会苦があるんだ
言っちゃうとこれが絶対避けられないでしょ？年取ることはね
お釈迦様 これを乗り越えられますよ
え？仏になったら年取らなくて死ななくて済むんだ
ありがてえことや 騙される
こんなくだらない話言ってるわけじゃない
正見のことを言ってるんです
あの 相対性抜けたら生老病死は苦じゃないんです
だって無常だからね 無常っていうことは条件に依存しない真理なんです
それだったら別にっていうことになるんです
だから我々の悩み苦しみは自作自演なんです
自作自演といっても罠にかけられていますよ
自分の目で耳で聞いて判断しなくちゃいけない
判断は相対的 判断は自分にとっては正しい
だから人に却下されるのは大嫌い
それで悩み 苦しみ 千五百の煩悩が生まれるんです
嫉妬 落ち込み 傲慢 卑下慢
他を軽視すること 自分をかなり高く評価すること
へつらい いろんな煩悩があるんです
寂しい 陰気臭い とまどい
まあたくさん 千五百もある
それが相対性理解していないからなんです
だから我々はいつでも相対的に判断しているんだと
一つも最終的な真実ではありません
すぐ変わっちゃいます
美味しいと言った食べ物には
それからまずいということにもなります
まずいと思った食べ物にある時は美味しいということになるんだよ
あのー 昔から人間はキャニバリスティックじゃないでしょ
キャニバルというのは自分の肉食べることに言われる
人間が人間の肉食べる
キャニバルというんですね
なんかどこかで昔聞いた話ありますね
なんか飛行機で行って
飛行機がどこかで壊れちゃってね
みんな次から次へと雪の中で死んじゃうんですね
生き残った人々は人の肉を食べたんです
だから それ悪いとは言いませんよ
自分の友達がもう次から次と死んでいて
まだまだ生きている人々は食べるもの何もなくて
周りも何もない じゃあ仕方がない
この肉食べましょう それで生き延びたという話があるんですね
だから 生きる世界 そういう世界なんです
今更人間の肉食べる それも友達の
信じられないでしょ 大丈夫です
それは条件によって起こる
条件によって起こる びっくりしなくてもいいです
はい そこで次のスライドに入ってみると
相対性を超える 我々は我々ではない
お釈迦様がね こと間違いない
相対性を超えることを教えているんですね
当然わかるでしょ 相対性を超えなくちゃいけない
でなきゃ この罠の中でぐるぐるぐるぐる回っているだけ
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみの中でぐるぐる回っているだけです
成功してまた失敗しました
間違った よくできましたとか
そんな罠で回っているだけ
今日は大成功で 明日は大失敗で
それも順番で回るならばわかりますよ
今日は成功 明日は大失敗だから
明後日は大成功 そうじゃないんですね
なんかそういう世界ですね
昨日も成功 明日...昨日も成功
今日も成功で 明日は失敗でということはありません
だから条件によってこうこうで回されているんですよ
だから あんたどこまで回されるのか
いい加減にしないのか
この輪廻転生 輪廻転生っていうのは
いろんな輪廻転生あるんですよ
死んでからどこか生まれる話じゃないんで
それもあるんだけど これたった一側面だけ
あらゆる輪廻転生があるんです
はい ぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐる回る
回るだけだから成長ない
回るんだったら螺旋で回ってよ
イスパイラル そうすると上がるでしょ
今イスパイラルで回ることを教えたんです
条件の一番やりやすいところから
どんどんどんどん今 相対性乗り越えるところまで
これイスパイラル 回っているんだけど
上に行くんです だから我々は限界に束縛されないで
正解は何なのかと 誰にも却下できない
否定できない 変わらない
正解はなんなのか これ見つかりましょう
一人一人 ブッダが見つかる
ブッダの問題は解決しました
だから あ 私のちょうだいは成り立たないんですね
だから私は私の習慣を持ってるんだから
私は私でこの正解を見つからなくちゃいけないんです
実質の姿 すなわち正解を見つけましょう
そこで物事 話を早くしたいんだから
私はこれあのー ブッダの発見した真理書いたんです
一 一切の現象は諸行 因縁によって生じて消えるので判断不可能です
我々判断するでしょ 判断不可能です
だって無常だから で シャボン玉見て
あ なんて綺麗です あのもう判断できる？綺麗で言ったけど
あのシャボン玉変わってるんだから
シャボン玉 光に当てると綺麗ですよ
何せ綺麗かとよく見てください
あの 成分がぐるぐるぐる回ってるんですね
空気の中に そうすると光が当たっていろんな模様が見えてくるんですね
芸術家作品のように だから綺麗に見える
皆様そこまで真剣にシャボン玉遊びやってないね
顔を見たらわかるよ [笑い]私は出っ kennt なのはそういうことを禁止されていたんだけど
やるとば真面目にやる
[笑い] だからシャボン玉見て
私は光に当てて すぐ弾けたんだけどね
あの水と石鹸成分がふーっとこうやって回るんですね
回るとなんかいろんな美しい模様が出てきてパチッと消えちゃう
だからそこで見て あ 終わったっていうことにした方がいいでしょ
そこで同じシャボン玉もう一度作りましょうとかね
友達とこちょこちょ すごいこんな感じの象さんの形が見えたよとか
友達に見せてシャボン玉
象さんの顔が出てくるんですね
それで馬鹿にされるんですね
なんで馬鹿なやつ ただのシャボン玉でしょ？いいえ
あの この前に作ったもので
ちゃんと象さんのような形が見えましたよとかね
もうちょっと待ってくださいと
苦労するけど一回きりですね
私はこれは雲をよく見ていたんですね
ちっちゃい頃 雲を見て頭の中でいろんなもう画策を当てるんですね
象さんだ 白鳥だ 蚊取りだとかね
山が現れてるんだとかね
それで山のように雲を見たら
見てるとなんか山が崩れていくんですね
そこででっかい翼を広げている鳥のように見えて
ああ 鳥だとなんと鳥が崩れていくんですね
そういう風に観察したら
判断できませんね これで番目
諸行は無常 苦 無我です
諸行 現象です 瞬間です
変わる 実体もない 無常
苦 無我です 正見というのはその見方ですね
これが正解で正見です
だから正見に至って自由です
偏見の世界はハチャメチャ無限に終わりがない
正見の世界はものすごいシンプルで
全ての浄化が作用がある
悩まない 期待はしません
判断もしません はい 次の才能はありまして
そこでだいたい終了になります
一切の見解見解がないことが正見
ブッダが教える正見とは一切見解ないことです
えーと 智慧は相対的で偏見になる知識ではありません
だから知識でもないんです
はい そういうわけで これは悟りの境地なんです
仏道は正見で始まるんだけど
正見で終わっちゃうんです
正見がある人は終わり
それで仏道やりたいだったら正見から始めてください
なんかなぜそんなこと言うの？矛盾でしょと
螺旋だからね 登る ぐるぐる回されます
でも回すたびに上に行く
だから最初は世間常識から始めてください
世間常識で正しいというものを認めて
でも執着しないで どんどん上に
このネックになるのは私は正しい
それは絶対捨ててください
それは邪見にしがみつくこと
ディッティ パラーマーサというものです
邪見にしがみついたら
悟りは一切ないです 第一ステージに悟ったと
預流果になったとはディッティを破ったこと
見解を破ったことになります
はい それからもう一つ余分な話ですけど
悟った人は世間常識認めないでしょ
だから変ですね 付き合えないねと思われるんですね
これも言ってるんです
阿羅漢は世間の人間じゃない
あなた方とは交じらない
と言っても 阿羅漢に達した人々は
世間の人々とものすごくうまくいくんです
これが面白いんです なぜかというと
子供がカエルさんを見せて
このカエルってかわいいでしょうにと言うと
阿羅漢は知っていますよ
それは阿羅漢にとっては可愛く
可愛い 可愛くない どうでもないんです
しかし 子供の見方から見れば
すごく可愛い ああ そうでしょうね
どこら辺可愛いの？と聞いてみることはできます
だからどこら辺どこら辺可愛い？と
そうすると子供喜んじゃって
この鼻なんか三角形ですよね
これかっこいいねとかね
口 口 口すごく大きくてかっこいいねとかね
こちらの方はね これこうやって動くんだからね
これかっこいいとかね
手を見せて この指がね
赤いですとかね そうすると
子供の世界は阿羅漢はよく理解する
それで子供があ 私のこと
このおじいちゃんはよくわかってるんだと
じゃあ仲良くしましょう
それで阿羅漢が修行しているんです
だから夫婦喧嘩したら
お釈迦様がね お前はバカじゃないかと
と怒ることはないんです
ダンナと喧嘩した奥さんの立場が知っているんです
説明してる あなたはこういう風に
こういう風に こういう風に見たんだから
こんな感じでこんな感じになって
今怒っている 最後の質問します
それで幸せ？と言ったら
相手いえ これが幸せじゃない
本当に苦しいんだな わかった
旦那さんに聞いた あなたの気持ちわかる
あんたはこういう風に
こういう風に こういう風に奥さんのこと見たんだから
喧嘩になっちゃって ものすごく別れになっちゃって
今すごい怒ってるでしょ
これで幸せ？幸せじゃない
うん まあそういうね いさぎよく捨てた方がいいんじゃない？とアドバイスすることはできる
あなた容災 あなた無罪はないんです
ブッダの場合は 夫婦が喧嘩したら
この場合は奥さんの方が悪い
この場合は旦那の方が悪いとは一切ないです
みんな悪いんです 最初から見解にしがみついてる
だからそれを教えたよ
だから阿羅漢になった人々は
この世の中で誰へともうまくいくんです
皆様ですよ 問題は 仏教をなめてだけで
なんかちょっと変になってるんですね
みんなと仲良くしないで
時々私に文句を言うんだ
自分が仏教を好きで 仏教を勉強したり瞑想もしたりするんだけど
それにしたら家の連中は大反対ですよ
どうしようかというのは困ってるんだよと
私から正直なところ あなたは正しく仏教をやっていないでしょうにと
正しくやったら 家の人は反対するはずもない
だって仏教を学んだ人は
前より一層より正しく家の気持ちわかるんだと
だから喧嘩していたならば
もう喧嘩なくなっているはずなんです
収入がなくて困っていたならば
仏教学んだら収入はものすごく間に合うようにやっているはずなんです
だからトラブっちゃったら仏教のせいじゃないんです
皆様方は仏教の偏見で取ったせいなんです
我は正しいという 仏教では勇災無災ないんです
あなた悪人なんだ 善人はないんです
あんた方みんな苦しんでいるんだから
偏見に なんて言いますかね
束縛されている 偏見にとらわれない
偏見は偏見で正解ではありません
だから正解を見つけなさい
正解を見つける方法っていうのは
この相対性と非相対性を区別して理解する
だから高いというためには何か比較しなくちゃいけない
綺麗というためには何か比較しなくちゃいけない
この比較する頭のあれが消えちゃったら
全て それは大乗仏教ではこうシューニャという言葉で言っているんです
お釈迦様はシューニャという言葉を使ってはいるんです
あまりシューニャという言葉は派手に使わない
なぜならば シューニャというと俗世間的なゼロという意味が出てくるんだから
それちょっと使いづらいんだけど
仕方がなく使ってはいるんです
はい それで次のスライドに行きます
使い捨て これは阿羅漢の生き方なんです
使い捨ての生き方 使い捨て
楽じゃない あの 1万  2万円の皿でご飯を食べるというよりは
紙皿でね 使った後に捨てる
楽です 正見智慧がある人に使い捨ての世界が現れる
全て無常ですからね すぐ別ですから
変わっちゃうんだからね
だから取るものないんです
持ち運びたい 執着したい
大事にしたい 守りたい
しがみつきたいものは一切ありません
全て無常です 手すりを使って階段を上がるが
手すりを持って行こうとはしない
皆様 それやるはずです
結構大変やと思います
手すりを使い捨てなんです
階段を降りるとか上がる時
でも助かりますよ 手すりがあったら
私も今足が弱いんだから
ちゃんと手すりをつかまります
でも使い捨て 使い捨てなければ
階段は上がることも下りることもできない
手すりにつかまっているんですね
相対的無常の肉体を超えるまで使い捨ての理論で管理するんです
阿羅漢の方々もご飯食べますよ
喉が渇いたら水を飲みますよ
体が疲れたら寝ますよ
でも使い捨て理論 ああ
寝なくては 健康な体を維持するためには
一日8時間寝なくちゃとかね
こんなくだらん話はない
肉体はもう無常だから
肉体が疲れてもう機能しない状態だったら休ませてあげる
肉体の部品交換が必要だと思ったら
その分だけ水とご飯をあげる
美味しいものは関係ないんです
だから自分 体さえ使い捨て
自然で使います で 体壊れたら終わり
涅槃に入ります はい 次に行きます
はい 今日はブッダの言葉がないとね
困りますから ブッダの言葉を紹介して話を終了します
で 早く終わります 時間ちょうどいいです
ヴィッチャーチョコーディッカリプッバンガーナークシャラーナンダンマーナンサマーバッティアアンヌデーヴァヒロッタッパン
正見 これは正見なんですけど
お釈迦様ヴィッチャー
無明の反対 明と使ってるんですね
が 善に達する道の先頭になります
だから善の道っていうのは
解脱も安穏も安らぎの道
最初に正見やってください
しかし 仲間が必要です
一緒に仲間が慚愧がお供になります
慚愧の話 昨日さんたちがなんか喋ったんですね
慚愧 それは旅にお供になる二人ですね
慚愧っていうのは 悪行為を恥じること
悪行為を怖がること 善行為をやることなんですね
これで正見を育てようとする
次に行きます ヴィッチャーガタッセディッカリッダスマサンマーディッティパホーティ
理性がある人に正見の実践ができます
だから見解のことを理解して
じゃあ正見頑張りますというと
正見がどんどんどんどん出てくる
正見がある人に正思惟の実践ができます
サンマーディッティッササンマーサンカッポーパホーティ
八正道でしょ 一個だけやってください
正しい正見になったら考えること全て正しいんです
オートで だから一個だけやればいいんです
はい 次のスライドに行きます
サンマサンカッパサンマーワーチャーオーパヒワーチャパホーティ
正思惟がある人に正語の実践ができます
サンマーワーチャッセサンマカンマントーパホーティ
正語がある人に正語の実践ができます
サンマカンマントッササンマアージーオーパホーティ
正業がある人に正命の実践ができます
正命っていうのは生活ですね
仕事 だから正しい見解あること
正見がある人は全部自動的に思考が正しい
言葉が正しい やること正しい
仕事を選んでも正しい仕事をすると不正はやらない
サンマージワッササンマワーヤモパホーティ
正命がある人に正精進の実践ができます
サンマーヤーマッササンマ・・・だって同じ繰り返しではない
わざとそう訳したんです
一応 サンマーワーヤーマッササンマーサティパホーティ
正精進がある人に正念の実践ができます
サンマーサティッササンマーサマーディパホーティ
正念のある人に正定の実践ができます
八正道終わり だから仏道は八正道であって
一個で全て完成します
それは判断する世界から判断しない心に達する
というか 判断する次元を乗り越える
その都度判断はしてあげる
でもそこではない はい
最後のスライドだと思います
そういうわけで 正見を完成して完成して仏道を完成しましょう
相対的な幻想の次元を超えて真理に達するということなんですね
はい 話はわり難しかったんだけどね
ポイントだけちょっとあと
また参考にして勉強してもいいんだけど
覚えるポイントっていうのは
見解っていくらでもある
いくらでもあり 見解まとめて正解は作れない
それをよく覚えてください
百人の意見をまとめて一つの意見にしたっても
それも見解なんですね
偏見 この道ではありません
はい それで話は終了です
はい 失礼をします  ...今日はあれですから
ウェーサーカ祭りですので
お釈迦様がブッダになったことはとても大事なことで
初転法輪経を今日の主峰の経典として読み上げます
で ちょっと私はちょっと早くしていますけど
一応省略版 初転経で長いんだけど
省略版時点ではいきます
ああ 聞こえない お釈迦様の最初の説法ですね
はい サッサーリ  サード
サード ナモータッサバガヴァトーアラハトーサンマサンブッダッサーナモータッサバガヴァトーアラハトーサンマサンブッダッサーナモータッサバガヴァトーアラハトーサンマサンブッダッサ
ー
イティピソーバガヴァーアラハンサンマサンブッドーヴィンチャーチャラナサンパンノー スガトーローカヴィドゥアヌッタロープリサダンマサーラティーサッダーデーヴァマヌッサ
ナム ブッドーバガヴァーティ
スワッカートバガヴァターダンモサンディッティコーアカーリコーエイヒパッシコローパナイコー パッチャッタンヴェーリタンボーウィンヨーヒキーシュパティパン
ノーバガヴァトーサーヴァカサンゴーウジュパティパンノーバガヴァトーサーヴァカサンゴーニャーヤパティパンノーバガヴァトーサーヴァカサンゴーサーミーチパテ
ィパンノーバガヴァトーサーヴァカサンゴーヤリダンチャッターリプリサユガーネマッタプリサポッガラーエーサバガヴァトーサーヴァカサンゴー
アウネイヨウバウネイヨウダッキーネイヨーアンジャリカーラミーヨーアヌッタランプンニャッキッタンローカッサーティ
エーテーナサッチャヴァッジェーナパートゥタンラタナッタヤンエーテーナサッチャヴァッジェーナホートゥタジャイマンガランエーテーナサッチャヴァッジェーナサダーソッティーバワントゥテー
テーワメシュッタンエカンサマヤンバガヴァーバーラナシヤンゲーリティーティパタネーニガダーエータトラゴーバガヴァーパンチャヴァッキーエーラーマッビクク
ーアーマンテーシーグウェーメービッカヴェーアンタパンパジテーナナセーヴィタンバー
ヨーチャーヤンカーラーメーシュバームシュカリカーニヨーゴーヒーノーガンモーポートゥージャニコ
アネリヨーアナッタサンニトーヨーチャーヤンアッタキラマターニヨーゴー ドゥッカオーアネリヨーアナッタサンニトー
エーテーテービッカヴェーウポーアンテーアヌパガンママッジマーパティパダータターガテーナアピヤンブッダー
チャックカラーニーニャーナカラーニーウパサマーヤーアビニャーヤサンボーダーヤニッバーナーヤサンワッタティーカタモーチャサービッカヴェーマッジマーパティパダー
タターガテーナアピサンブッダーチャックカラーニーニャーナカラーニーウパサマーヤーアビニャーヤサンボーダーヤニッバーナーヤサンワッタティーアヤメーワアリーヨウアッタンディコーマンコー
セイヤティーダンサッマーディッティサッマーサンカッポーサッマーワーチャーサッマーカッマントー
サッマージーボーサッマーワーヤモーサッマーサティサッマーサマーディ
アヤンコーサービッカヴェーマッジマーパティパダータターガテーナアピサンブッダー
チャックカラーニーニャーナカラーニーウパサマーヤーアビニャーヤサンボーダーヤニッバーナ
サンパッティダンパナ ビッカヴェ ドゥッカム アリヤ サッチャン
ジャーティピ ドゥッカ ジャラーピ ドゥッカ ヤーティピ ドゥッコ マラナンピ ドゥッカム アッピェヒ
サンパヨーゴ ドゥッコ ピェヒ ヴィッパヨーゴ ドゥッコ ヤンピンチャン ネラパティタンピ ドゥッカム
サンキッテナ パンチ パダーナ カンダ ドゥッカヤ イダンコパナ ビッカヴェ
ドゥッカ サムデヤン アリヤ サッチャン ヤヤン タンナー ポーノ パリカナン ディラーガ サーガター
タトラ タトラ アビランディニ セッヤティ ダン カーマタンナー バヴァタンナー アビバヴァタンナー
イダンコパナ ビッカヴェ ドゥッカ ニローダ ナローダン アリヤ サッチャン ヨ タッサーエヴァ
タンナーヤ シェーサ ヴィラーガ ニローダチャー ゴーパティ ニッサッゴ ブッティ アナラヨ イダンコパナ ビッカヴェ
ドゥッカ ニローダガーミニ パティパダーリヤ サッチャン アヤメワリヨ アッタンジコマッゴ
セッヤティ ダン サммаディッティ サммаサンカッポ サッマワーチャ サммаカムマント
サッマージーヴォ サッммаワーヤーモ サッマ サティ サммаサマディ
イダン ドゥッカム アリヤ サッチャンティメ ビッカヴェ プッペ アヌッヌッステー スダンメー ス
チャッコム ウダパーディ ニャーナム ウダパーディ パンニャー ウダパーディ ヴィッジャー ウダパーディ
アーローコ ウダパーディ タンコパニダン ドゥッカム アリヤ サッチャン
パリニャイアンティメ ビッカヴェ プッペ アヌッヌッステー スダンメー ス
チャッコム ウダパーディ ニャーナム ウダパーディ パンニャー ウダパーディ ヴィッジャー ウダパーディ アーローコ ウダパーディ
タンコパニダン ドゥッカム アリヤ サッチャン パリニャータンティメ ビッカヴェ
プッペ アヌッヌッステー スダンメー ス
チャッコム ウダパーディ ニャーナム ウダパーディ パンニャー ウダパーディ ヴィッジャー ウダパーディ アーローコ ウダパーディ
ダン ドゥッカ サムデヤン アリヤ サッチャンティメ ビッカヴェ
プッペ アヌッヌッステー スダンメー ス
チャッコム ウダパーディ ニャーナム ウダパーディ パンニャー ウダパーディ ヴィッジャー ウダパーディ アーローコ ウダパーディ
タンコパニダン ドゥッカ サムデヤン アリヤ サッチャン
パハータッバンティメ ビッカヴェ プッペ アヌッヌッステー スダンメー ス
チャッコム ウダパーディ ニャーナム ウダパーディ
パンニャー ウダパーディ ヴィッジャー ウダパーディ アーローコ ウダパーディ
タンコパニダン ドゥッカ サムデヤン アリヤ サッチャン
パヒーナンティメ ビッカヴェ プッペ アヌッヌッステー スダンメー ス
チャッコム ウダパーディ ニャーナム ウダパーディ パンニャー ウダパーディ ヴィッジャー ウダパーディ アーローコ ウダパーディ
ダン ドゥッカ ニローダン アリヤ サッチャンティメ ビッカヴェ
プッペ アヌッヌッステー スダンメー ス
チャッコム ウダパーディ ニャーナム ウダパーディ パンニャー ウダパーディ ヴィッジャー ウダパーディ アーローコ ウダパーディ
タンコパニダン ドゥッカ ニローダン
アリヤ サッチャン サッチパ タッバンティメ ビッカヴェ プッペ
アヌッヌッステー スダンメー ス
チャッコム ウダパーディ ニャーナム ウダパーディ パンニャー ウダパーディ ヴィッジャー ウダパーディ
アーローコ ウダパーディ タンコパニダン ドゥッカ ニローダン アリヤ サッチャン サッチパ タンティメ ビッカヴェ
プッペ アヌッヌッステー スダンメー ス
チャッコム ウダパーディ ニャーナム ウダパーディ パンニャー ウダパーディ ヴィッジャー ウダパーディ アーローコ ウダパーディ
ダン ドゥッカ ニローダガーミニ パティパダーリヤ サッチャンティメ
ビッカヴェ プッペ アヌッヌッステー スダンメー ス
チャッコム ウダパーディ ニャーナム ウダパーディ パンニャー ウダパーディ ヴィッジャー ウダパーディ アーローコ ウダパーディ
タンコパニダン ドゥッカ ニローダガーミニ パティパダーリヤ サッチャン
バーレタッバンティメ ビッカヴェ プッペ アヌッヌッステー スダンメー ス
チャッコム ウダパーディ ニャーナム ウダパーディ パンニャー ウダパーディ ヴィッジャー ウダパーディ アーローコ ウダパーディ
タンコパニダン ドゥッカ ニローダガーミニ パティパダーリヤ サッチャン
バーヴィタンティメ ビッカヴェ プッペ アヌッヌッステー スダンメー ス
チャッコム ウダパーディ ニャーナム ウダパーディ パンニャー ウダパーディ ヴィッジャー ウダパーディ アーローコ ウダパーディ
ヤワキィワンチャメ ビッカヴェ イメ サッス アリヤ サッテー セワンティ パリワッタンダワサカーラン
ヤターブータ ニャーナ ダッサナナン スビシュッドン アウォシネーワ タワーン ビッカヴェ
サデーワケー ローケー サマーラケー サブラフマケー サッサマナ ブラフマニヤー パヤー
サデーワ マヌッサーヤ アヌッタラン サッマ サンボーディン アビサンバッドドー パンチャン パッチャンニャーシン
ヤトチャコーメ ビッカヴェ イメ サッス アリヤ サッテー ス
セワンティ パリワッタンダワサカーラン ヤターブータ ニャーナ ダッサナン
スビシュッドン アウォシ アッターン ビッカヴェ サデーワケー ローケー サマーラケー サブラフマケー サッサマ
ナ ブラフマニヤー パヤー サデーワ マヌッサーヤ
アヌッタラン サッマ サンボーディン アビサンブッドドー パンチャンニャーシン
ニャーナン チャパナメ ダッサナン ウダパーディ
アプンプラーメ チェットー ヴィムッティ
アヤマンティ マージャーティ
ナッティダーニ プナンバーウォーティ
イダマポーチャ バガヴァー タマナー パンチャ バッキャ ビックー バガヴァトー アビナン バーイタン アビナンドゥッティ
イマスミン チャパナ ウェッイヤーカルナ マッシン バンヤラーネー アヤスマトー クンダンニャッサ
ヴィラジャン ヴィータマラン ダンマ チャッコム ウダパーディヤン キンチ サムデダン マン サッバンタン ニローダ ダンマンティ
パワッティテー チャパナ バガヴァー タダンマ チャッケ ブンマーデーヴァー サッバ マヌッサーヴェソン
エタン バガヴァー タバーラーナッスヤン イシパッタネ ニッガターヤ アヌッタラン ダンマ チャッカム パワッティタン
アッパティ ワッティヤン サマネー ナワー ブラフマネー ナワー デーヴェー ナワー マーレー ナワー
...
ブラフマーケーナチワローカスミンティ ブンマナンデーヴァーナ サッダン スットゥワ チャトゥマーラージカー
デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン チャトゥマーラージカーナンデーヴァーナーン
サッダン スットゥワ タヴァティンサー デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン タヴァシンサーナンデーヴァーナーン
サッダン スットゥワ ヤーマー デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン ヤーマーナンデーヴァーナーン サッダン スットゥワ
トゥシター デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン トゥシターナンデーヴァーナーン サッダン スットゥワ ニンマーナラテ
ィ デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン
ニンマーナラティーナンデーヴァーナーン サッダン スットゥワ パラニムミタヴァサヴァッティーノー デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン
パラニムミタヴァサヴァッティーナンデーヴァーナーン サッダン スットゥワ ブラフマパーヴィサッジャー デ
ーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン ブラフマパーヴィサッジャーナンデーヴァーナーン
サッダン スットゥワ ブラフマプローヒター デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン ブラフマプローヒターナンデーヴァーナーン
サッダン スットゥワ マハーブラフマー デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン マハーブラフマーナンデーヴァーナーン
サッダン スットゥワパリッターバー デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン パリッターバーナンデーヴァーナーン
サッダン スットゥワ アップマナーバー デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン アップマナーバーナン
デーヴァーナーン サッダン スットゥワ アパッサラー デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン アパッサラーナン
デーヴァーナーン サッダン スットゥワ パリットスバー デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン パリットスバーナンデーヴァーナーン
サッダン スットゥワ アップマナースバー デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン アップマナースバーナンデーヴァーナーン
サッダン スットゥワ シュバキンナーカー デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン シュバキンナーカーナンデーヴァーナーン
サッダン スットゥワ ヴェーハッパラ デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン ヴェーハッパラナンデーヴァーナーン
サッダン スットゥワ アヴィハー デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン アヴィハーデーヴァーナーン
アヴィハーナンデーヴァーナーン サッダン スットゥワ アタッパー デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン アタッパーナンデーヴァーナ
ーン サッダン スットゥワ
シュダッサー デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン シュダッサーナンデーヴァーナーン
サッダン スットゥワ シュダッシー デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン
シュダッシーナンデーヴァーナーン サッダン スットゥワ アカニッチャカー デーヴァー サッダマヌッサーヴェスン
エータン バガヴァター パーラーナ シヤン ニシパタネ ニガダー Ye アヌッタラングダンマチャッカム パワッティタン
アンプラティワッティヤン サマネーナワー ブラフマネーナワー デーヴェーナワー マーレーナワー ブラフムナーワー ケーナ チワローカスミンティー
イティヤテーナ カネーナ テーナ モーッテーナ ヤーヴァブラフマローカー サッドー アッブッガンチ
アヤンチャ ダササハッスリー ロカダートゥ カンピ サンパカンピ サンパレーヴィ アップマノー チャウラーローー
パーソー ローケー パートゥラーホーシ
アティカンマー デーヴァーナン デーヴァーヌバーヴァンティ
アタコー バガヴァー ウダーナン ウダーネーシ
アンヤーシヴァテボー コンダンヨー アンヤーシヴァテボー コンダンヨーホーティ
イティヒタン アースマトー コンダンニャッセ パンニャー...コンダンとコンダンニャット
コンダンニョッテーヴァ ナマンガホーシッティ
エーテーナ・サッチャヴァッジェーナ・パワトゥタン・ラタナッタヤン
エーテーナ・サッチャヴァッジェーナ・ホートゥテー・ジャイマンガラン
エーテーナ・サッチャヴァッジェーナ・サダースッティ・バヴァントゥテー
サッビトゥーヴァッジャントゥ サッバローゴー・ウィナッサトゥ マテー・バワットパンタラーヨ
スキーディーガーイコ パヴァバントゥ サッバマンガラン ラッカントゥ サッバデーワター
サッバブッダン パーヴェナ サダースッティ・バヴァントゥテー・バワンチュ サッバマンガラン
ラッカントゥ サッバデーワター サッバダンマヌバーヴェナ サダースッティ・バヴァントゥテー
バワンチュ サッバマンガラン ラッカントゥ サッバデーワター サッバサンガーヌバーヴェナ サダースッティ・バヴァントゥテー
アビワ...アイ ナッカッタヤッカ ブーターナム パーパンガ ニバーナ パリットッサーヌバーヴェナ アントゥテー サンヌパンデウィ
アーカワサッタ ジュンマッター デーワナーガ マヒンディーカ プンニャンタマン モーディットワ チラン ラッカントゥ
デーサナンガー カワサッタ ジュンマッター デーワナーガ マヒンディーカ
プンニャンタマン モーディットワ チラン ラッカントゥ デーサナンガー カワサッタ ジュンマッター デーワナーガ マヒンディーカ
プンニャンタマン モーディットワ チラン ラッカントゥ マンガラントゥ テーホウ ワッストゥカーレーナ
サッサ サンパッティ ホートゥジェ ピートー ホートゥ ローコーチェ ラージャー ホートゥ ダンニコー
イダンノーニャーティーナン ホートゥ スキター ホンチュニャーテー イダンノーニャーティーナン ホートゥ スキター ホンチュニャーテーヨー
イダンノーニャーティーナン ホートゥ スキター ホンチュニャーテーヨー
はい 最後にの最後の言葉を一緒に言ってください
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
はい 回向の  仏法僧の三宝に礼拝返し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに廻向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得られますように
イミナー プンニャ カンベーナ マノー タリッピヤン アウナッティティ ワチャナン ナメ マホートゥ パワッバヴェー
イミナー プンニャ カンベーナ マノー バーラサッパゲノー サタン サマーゲ モッホトゥ
ヤーワ ニッバーナ パッティヤー イミナー ワンダナ マーネナ ホージャー パリパッティヤーヌバーヴェナ
サッバ ドゥッカ ウィナッサントゥ
パーセヴァッキャ ワハン ホートゥ
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
はい 残りは大乗仏教の坊様方に任せます
はい それではこれにて
仏紀二千五百六十一年 のウェーサーカ祭
終了いたしました 皆さん
長い時間どうもありがとうございました